[Music]
hey what's up everybody today the 15th
of august
is the birthday anniversary of the late
paul rand the most famous and iconic
graphic designer
of all time we wanted to honor this
anniversary by taking a look at rand's
life
and career and introduce you to this
pioneer of design
and hopefully inspire you to go out
there and study his work and read some
of his books
on design there's no way we're going to
be able to cover
everything in one video but we will do
our best to hit some of the highlights
let's get started the years 1914
brooklyn new york paul ryan was born as
parrots
rosenbaum that's right guys he changed
his name
to paul brand later on in his career but
more on that later
between 1929 and 1934 he studied at the
pratt institute
parsons school of design and the art
students league yet despite this
he considers himself self-taught and in
a visit to no other than arts center the
school i graduated from and taught at
he mentioned that he learned design by
looking at other people's work
as schools back then weren't teaching
good design according to him
he taught himself by observing the work
of european greats like cassandra
and was often inspired by the work found
in design magazines like
gerbrash graphique which actually still
exists today but renamed
novum magazine his career started at a
very young age
it could be distinctly divided into
three main parts with some overlapping
here and there
the first is the editorial part ran
started his career creating stock
graphics for syndicate that sells them
to magazines and newspapers
but his major calling in editorial came
when esquire
and apparel arts now gq trusted him with
their art direction at the young age of
just 23.
can you believe that rand quashed any
suspicion about his art directorship
with a number of astounding covers
created for apparel arts that showcased
his mature design skills
and established him as a first rank
designer his most notable editorial work
however
was a series of covers he did for a
relatively small magazine called
direction
where he had total creative freedom the
covers were
revolutionary and a far cry from the
editorial style of those times
he drew inspiration from modern art
movements and made this amazing link
with graphic design applications
giving birth to timeless covers just
look at this
[Music]
now it was during this editorial phase
of his career that ran
devised the persona that is paul ran
changing his name from parrots rosenbaum
in what peter barons considers to be
rand's first and most enduring corporate
identity the second part of rand's
career is the advertisement part
in 1941 and for 13 years ran became the
art director of william h
weintraub's advertising agency brand's
work during this phase can still
be seen in the use of symbols that
convey multiple meanings
as well as a spirit of wit in today's
advertisements
before ran there was a big emphasis on
copy
and you would see ads with loads of copy
and minimal use of visuals
and when you see visual focus ads more
often than not
they were very cluttered paul rand
influenced by the european style of
design
approached ad design in a radically
different way he saw graphics and type
as a continuum when done right coherence
between the two can be achieved he
minimized the role of copy to its
essentials to breathe space into his
designs and maximize its relation to the
graphics producing ads
where graphics and type act as one unit
conveying the message of the ad
while at the same time injecting
elements of art beauty
and even wit all in service of selling a
product you can particularly see the
execution of these principles in his
terrific ads for
mr disney hats an amazing pairing of
graphics and type
hugely contributing to the main goal of
the ad which is to showcase the product
you can also witness the signature style
of paul rand in the wonderfully playful
ads for coronet brandy for which he
also designed the logo and if you paid
attention to his work so far
you'll see that almost always rand
signed his work
similar to what an artist does with his
paintings and when asked about this by
stephen heller
rand responded i signed simply as a way
of publicizing myself we have now
reached a third part of rand's career
and arguably the longest and most known
publicly
and that is corporate design rand is
responsible for some of the biggest
corporate identities to this day
and his logos often endured for decades
many of which
still are in use today rand's major
breakaway in the corporate design world
came in 1956
when ibm's watson jr hired
eliot noyes to create an
all-encompassing corporate design
program for ibm one of elliot's first
decisions was to hire the services of
paul rand
to redesign their corporate logo among
many other design contributions over the
following years
ren introduced the ibm logo in 1956
using the same letters and form we know
today sans the stripes
but ran was bothered by the rhythm the
letters created
considering the i a light with letter
the b as a medium with and the m the
widest
it created this ascending rhythm and it
didn't go well with him
he worked on solving this issue for
years and he came up with a 13-strike
version
of the ibm logo in 1967 with the eight
stripe version that's still in use today
following in 1972 making the ibm
corporate logo one of the longest
enduring logos
still in use today among his other major
logo designs that stood the test of time
include color forms logo in 1959
westinghouse logo in 1960 abc
cummins both in 1962 and the aiga logo
just to name a few guys just a really
interesting article online by
morningstar
founder joe monsuetto recalling the
events working with paul rand
on their new logo in 1991 but not every
great work of paul ran can still be seen
today
notable examples include the excellent
ups logo created in 1961.
it was discontinued in 2003 enron's logo
in 1996 one of the
last he worked on in yale university
press logo
in 1985 which yale phased out starting
in 2009
rand also taught at yale among other
universities for decades
but perhaps rand's most famous client
was none other than
steve jobs for which rand created the
next logo in 1986.
steve had just left apple and started
his new computer company
soon to be known as nex and he didn't
want another logo type for his new
company
he was inspired by logos that contain
symbols that can be used
independently of the logo type similar
to what apple had
the problem however was that to be able
to use the symbol independently of the
name of the company
it usually takes many years and tens of
millions of dollars to associate them
together
and paul rand solved that problem by
making steve a logo that contained the
name of the company
within the symbol itself don't look at
the back
first this is the front and don't get
scared this is not the design
steve talks in an interview on how rand
approached this challenge
as a problem that had to be solved
rather than an artistic challenge for
its own sake
this among many others showed the
distinct philosophy paul rand
had regarding logo design he often
approached logo design as a business
problem that needs to be solved
refusing to give clients several logo
options
in an interview with migs he gave an
ingenious analogy
of how when you go to the doctor he
doesn't give you options
he gives you the solution to your
problem you pay for it
then it's up to you whether or not you
take it and become better or not
and rand did the same with steve jobs
and his other clients rand was an avid
defender of simplicity
and design on the condition that a
terrific idea was in place
he didn't conform to trends and being
fashionable and often quoted ludwig mies
saying don't try to be original just try
to be good
he believed that logos don't have to
illustrate what the business does or
represent
and that they become meaningful only
after being used
seen and associated with the business
another unique trait of rand's logo
design
is the way he presents his logos he
prints out these brochures
as he calls them and there are small
booklets that show the evolution and
progression of the logo
and they are simply a master class in
logo presentation
and explaining the rationale behind some
of the decisions taken while creating
the logo
there's a wonderful snippet on youtube
of paul ryan unveiling the next logo to
steve jobs
and a bunch of next employees that you
should go check it out but i also wanted
to give you a quick look from one of
these booklets and it's for
education first back in 1994 it's one of
the highest resolution ones we could
find
and is a nice little journey through
rent's rationale behind its work
keep in mind guys ef is an international
education company that specializes in
language learning
now this is important to know to kind of
make sense of the decisions rand made
so let's take a look this is the front
cover and you will see
in a second how this cover sets up the
tone for what comes next
page one is for the title and you can
see his clean design aesthetics and use
of contrast we talked about earlier
i would imagine if the back of the front
cover was also white
it would have been much less interesting
in the next page ren gives a small
explanation on what a logo is
and what should be expected of it that's
really important because you have to
keep in mind
that these logos aren't just presented
to a company's in-house design
department
or marketing department there's usually
a number of top management and
department heads
present in the presentation and this
short explanation
helps by managing the expectation levels
through educating those who aren't very
familiar with the creative process
then he shows some of the exploration he
came up with and explains
why they were abandoned because they
didn't serve the purpose of the logos to
use
in the best possible way in the next
page you'll see the shape that ren goes
on to describe
as the embryo of a graphic idea
next rand introduces the final iteration
he settled on
and explains how this sound wave pattern
serves as an important
decorative and mnemonic purpose in
addition
adding an organic feel to the logo
provides a contrast to the straight
lines of the letters
in the next page rand explains how best
to partner the logo with accompanying
text
and in the next three pages rand
explains how important it is to pay
attention to design elements
like logo size logo positioning point
size
margin dimensions and paper material and
weight
he emphasizes the importance of treating
the logo with the same respect
you wish your company to be looked upon
and you see rand finishing off
in the same elegant way he started these
booklets made the experience of
presenting logos completely different
for the receiver
it turned it into an interactive journey
you feel like you're unwrapping a gift
with your own hands
paul rand did this three four in
five decades ago and the way he presents
this information
is just as clean and relevant today as
it was decades ago this is what we talk
about when we say that design
should aim to be timeless of course
rand's influence in corporate design
isn't limited to
coming up with an ingenious logo he
pioneered all aspects of corporate
design
and often turned mandatory aspects of a
company's business
into opportunities to inject some design
genius
the best examples of this are the annual
reports all public companies are
required to publish every year the
content of
an annual report design content
but today the state of typography is in
pretty bad
shape rand saw this as an opportunity to
showcase the company's identity
and turn what is usually a dull document
into interesting read
rand also perfected the art of the
package he had profound ideas on how to
treat materials
shapes and graphics he thought the
designer shouldn't only aim to convince
the hand nor please the eye but to
however lightly
touch the emotions and gratify the human
spirit you can see that rand never took
any aspect of design lightly
and it shows in its brilliant packaging
designs for ibm and westinghouse
among others he transformed product
packages that are usually boring and
generic
and turn them into beautiful pieces of
design and a worthy extension of the
company's identity
right in the customer's hands if you
think that's the extent of rand's
talents
you better think again rand was also an
amazing painter having worked on over a
hundred book covers
and even a movie poster paul together
with his first wife anne
published four children's books and did
the writing and paul the drawings
they also designed their home in
connecticut in 1953
a modern masterpiece that minimizes
friction with its surroundings
the rand house received many accolades
and was considered one of the 10 best
houses of 1953
by interiors magazine had enough i
didn't think so either
ren also has four main brilliant books
on design that give us
a glimpse into his mind and don't get me
started on his posters
throughout rand's career he produced
timeless posters that still resonate
with graphic designers to this day
just look at these oh and this brilliant
poster for ibm which is one of steve
jobs favorite pieces of work by paul
rand this poster has a funny story
as ibm didn't really want to adopt it in
their identity at first
and only did so over the years to extend
where today
if you go to ibm's website in their
favicon
which is the tiny picture next to the
website name in the browser tab
they're using the b how cool is that
paul's work has been a beacon of
inspiration for many great designers
past and present his style and teachings
have been referenced and talked about by
the likes of lou danziger
whose rand's book thoughts on design
helped him clarify many design issues on
his mind
and emmy award-winning title designer
kyle cooper
who actually studied under ram rand's
mark and influence can be seen in many
creatives work
and of course the list goes on and on
and after more than six decades of
design genius at the age of 82
paul passed away in 1996 in his last
year ren gave us four logos
and published his last book from lascaux
to brooklyn
paul ryan who steve jobs describes as
having a slightly tough exterior
but a teddy bear on the inside truly is
the complete artist
he was self-taught left a mark on the
editorial stage from a very young age
conquered the advertising world and
simply pioneered corporate design
he painted taught wrote books and most
importantly
he inspired his work had the power to
change
industries outlive media and endure for
decades as if it were created only
yesterday
he believed that it's a designer's job
to improve the general quality of
life in fact he called it the only
reason for our existence
these are the marks of a legendary
designer and it is why
so many designers look up to him and
consider him the most famous graphic
designer of all time
i hope this journey through mr rand's
career inspired you to go
out there and look him up get to know
his work better
you can find everything we showed and
talked about in this video and much much
more
online i encourage you to study the work
and life of the design greats like paul
rand
who set the foundations for contemporary
art and design
that we all take for granted today
that's it for me in this video
i will see you in the future happy
birthday mr rand